hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
RO today oh this isn't so much fun we've
been having so much fun making like
crazy videos we've been hanging out
we've been a tasting things you've been
teaching me new techy things yeah are
you ready girl
[Music]
okay are we eating the whole thing yeah
really we also have a video on her
channel too so I'll put a link in the
description or you guys can check that
out after watching this this is exciting
I love doing unboxing videos and I'm so
glad you're gonna be joining me for this
was my second unboxing the first one we
did okay was with you yeah the glasses
snap your glasses well this is a thermos
essentially but it's upgraded for our
today's you know busy lifestyles and we
want to have our coffee to be the
genuine tempature these are actually
sold at Starbucks so I thought this is
gonna be a perfect unboxing for us it's
a mug it's a high-tech mug yeah and it
basically will keep your drink at
whatever temperature you want for about
two hours and there's an app I love
coffee and I like technology I'm not the
greatest at it but just needs teaching
me yeah it's designed for our lifestyle
hmm it says temperature matters and it
has three things in the back precise
simple and customizable the simple we
shall see we shall cuz if I can do it
then you can really put that on the box
like you can underline it you can bold
it relevant yeah good simple and I'm
like it is well today we had a very
special night this doesn't usually make
very many appearances on my channel but
this is like usually open food we've
gotten so many things I know everybody
is it's crazy I'm so sorry it actually
matches your outfit today we did not
plan that that's just happening yeah
this is just what I picked up off the
floor today alright okay okay we're
gonna if I just sort of relieved it it's
a coffee mug yeah I just don't really
know I think we started with a pot I'd
started from the bottom now we're here
yes very good it's good cutting that's
it that's
I have a funny story about cutting boxes
open one time my sister got so excited
we got a package in the mail she had
these big scissors and she went to her
guru she's had it open and she cut a
hole out of my dress
oh my hosta her hair to approve me her
wait so the dress was in the box and
then she cut oh got through the box my
okay she felt so bad and I love her so
much I was like it's no big deal it's
black we'll just so the piece together
and we did I wore it nobody knew that's
incredible nobody there it's a good
story though yeah it was really funny oh
this is already happening okay do you
want a help here oh my gosh I just bug
here we go think I just focus okay this
feels like it's a birthday or like
Christmas or soldados oh I love unboxing
whoo
so it's called the Ember this is another
box a box inside of a box oh this looks
really good oh wow look Justine I don't
want a van I don't want to take this a
moment oh no this is all on you this
feels pretty good to just do this it
looks good I don't want to break it oh
oh oh we've got something to cut we've
got something to cut oh we've got two
stickies on the side on the top and the
bottom get it get it get it yeah Oh
doesn't really have a smell I don't
smell like you feel kinda happy you see
I mean oh yeah
it's it's got a nice little weight to it
yeah what's this for so that you turn to
adjust the temperature this is a
temperature gauge so this these are our
directions Quick Start Guide oh gosh oh
there's more in here well let's get
those out okay so download the app to
pair press the logo yeah it's hand wash
only lid can be washed in the top rack
of your dishwasher though oh look at
this
this is our charging dog let's try yeah
let's do this
two pair press and hold the Ember logo
over six seconds hold the list button
yeah
okay hold it good for 6xu
I think it's not on oh really
does it still say hello oh it's talking
look it is deep Justine look at lights
up it like oh so it looks like we've got
some battery life so that's good I
already have the app if it's on power it
off first but powered off yeah and press
and hold the amber logo for six seconds
but like I'm pressing and like I don't
feel like anything's happening no smart
coffee mugger knows it's empty
and oh it showed up oh they found each
o'the at but showed up it showed up I'm
look they're becoming friends oh this is
so fun maybe I'm just gonna take it off
this and then okay I'm gonna tap it okay
and then is it gonna find it okay this
is so silly
come on open it up get started get
started if it's on power it off by
pressing and holding the amber logo for
three seconds well I'm getting very
upset I'm getting how to do that
very bossy I'm getting the pairing
option again do you need my Wi-Fi no I
don't know you're funny it's a funny one
okay okay we had to cut and we had a
focus and really just working on some
things
okay I'm gonna sign in now it's asking
me to name my ember what should we need
you couldn't name your mom's name it oh
my gosh there's so many coffee names
still we named it Jon Snow do we name it
snow do we name it Charmander it has an
attack called ember so we're gonna name
them Charmander good and this perf that
axe his attack that's so cute okay let's
say vigor attack so right now it's
saying that our mug is empty should we
even should we give it slowly fill it up
girl here we go oh yeah
just ease it I used to be a barista so
let's just go for it
are you ready girl I'm ready I okay now
when I was a barista and I used to be a
waitress all I used to do is just in my
mind I would be like I'm not gonna drop
it and then most the time that would not
happen I stopped breathing for like that
entire
story okay it's okay ready set go go for
it just go for it don't even know
anything about anything else and I won't
feel it past the max line because there
is a perfect answer
perfect toe at all fits in there
perfectly okay so it still says it's
empty on my oh you gotta update it uh oh
it still says it's empty no it's full
now
uh uh we've got drink in there there's
drinking the cup like I've built
computers before this is a mug that
heats your drink and connects to an app
there blue team yeah I've got my drink
in and things making me so upset that I
don't even want to enjoy my beverage
anymore things give it a little love
just tell your phone actually it is cold
out is it so cold so I just said it to
130 degrees
whose is heating you I don't know safety
instructions you don't touch the metal
inside with your fingers I just feel
like we're having look there's something
not right with this I feel like our
ember might be broken
Charmander is being sassy today term it
Scott I'm not even running the new one
okay okay
behind your this is step four find your
perfect temperature is it heating I just
want to tell you we're following these
directions step by step there's like two
there's two steps literally to make this
thing work and things are not quite
working and yeah like are we gonna walk
around like this I think the problem is
it maybe needs to charge for a full day
it doesn't say that in the instructions
but maybe just this mug little
Charmander he didn't come as charged as
he thinks he is
I mean it said that's pretty charged so
maybe we'll just leave it here for like
a couple hours maybe I seen some
happiness
yeah he loves coffee yeah alright guys
well that's it for the ember mug
indefinitely my expectations I think
were maybe set a little bit too high for
this they were really high cuz it's
coffee rounded well thanks for watching
go check out Rose Channel we've got some
fun videos over there we've done so many
fun collabs
yeah we've been making fun videos lately
I know hopefully next time I'll bring
something over that actually works it
works
charmander's he's just a little finicky
off of his charging station that's
cookie somebody's upset the Charmander
is not working cookies like what what do
you mean there's no coffee for me
remember all right guys we'll thank so
much for watching I will see you guys in
the next video make sure you go check
out roads channel we've got another fun
video that we did on hers and I'm so
excited it's been so much fun all right
well I'm gonna just leave this plugged
in for the rest of it yeah we'll just
leave a beer bye ladies come on you can
do it make me so upset come on stop
[Music]
we are talk about this thing let's just
let's discuss not only do we have a
bunch of problems in the beginning
getting this set up and get it to
actually charge we did eventually get it
to charge to a point that we're able to
use it this is basically like the
biggest disappointment if you can see oh
sorry sorry this thing doesn't work any
longer and it refuses a charge now it's
been a really long time since something
is upsetting me this much mostly because
I love coffee so much and I love this
cup and I love the concept so I guess I
can say I don't recommend this maybe
they're working on another one maybe
there's some recalls but yes that brings
me to the end of this video I just
wanted to give you guys a quick little
update we did a really fun video on Rose
Channel we were trying the game candy
[Music]
I'll put a link in the description and
an annotation right at the end of this
video where you guys can check that out
go say hi to ro and hopefully that video
will lift your spirits because I know is
going to lift mine after the
disappointment of this Cup
[Music]